et pour aller plus loin nous sommes sont
ce gâteau avec caroline mécary avocate
également membre du conseil national des
barreaux bonsoir caroline mécary merci
d'être avec nous c'est pas vraiment
fréquent de voir le monde de la justice
dans son ensemble dans la rue comme ça
des juges avec des ados c'est du jamais
vu mais voilà c'est quasi inédit c'est
du jamais vu notamment ça a démarré avec
la tribune qui a été signé le 23
novembre par plus de 3000 magistrats
professionnels aujourd'hui il y à 7700
personnels de justice magistrats
greffiers qui l'ont signé je rappelle
qu'en france il ya neuf mille magistrats
professionnels et que donc c'est inédit
la cour de cassation aussi a pris
position les syndicats de magistrats du
système administratif au sont aussi
venus au soutien les avocats tout le
monde tout le monde des robes n'en peut
plus en réalité nous sommes au bord du
burn out réellement quand on vous dit
qu'on manque de moyens humains et
matériels c'est une réalité et ce à une
répercussion sur les justiciables
pourquoi est ce qu'on met trois ans pour
avoir un jugement devant le conseil des
prud'hommes ya pas assez de juges pour
juger on va évidemment parler renée mais
non c'est très intéressant vous avez
raison d'être passionnés parce que
l'heure est grave semble-t-il mais la
question qu'on se pose pourquoi
maintenant et pourquoi est ce pire
maintenant est ce que j'allais on s'est
juste un ras-le-bol de plusieurs années
de ça finalement est-ce que ça s'est
aggravé là alors en fait j'ai il ya il
ya pardon de le dire comme ça il ya une
goutte d'eau qui a fait déborder le vase
qui est le suicide d'une jeune m'a dit
magistrate de 29 ans au mois d'août 2021
dans le nord de la france c'était une
juge placé c'est à dire une juge qui
remplaçait les jugements quand les juges
malade et elle s'est retrouvée dans une
situation personnelle au regard du
travail qui était le sien qui l'a
conduit à se suicider et ça a fait un
tel écho parce qu'en réalité la
souffrance au travail des magistrats
c'est quelque chose qui était
diagnostiquée notamment par le syndicat
de la magistrature dans un rapport qui a
été rendu il ya deux ans donc on est
arrivé à un point de rupture voilà c'est
ça on est au bord de l'implosion et vous
avez raison ça ne marche pas ça ne
marche pas que maintenant c'est à dire
que c'est aussi le résultat d'un abandon
de l'institution judiciaire m au moins
depuis nicolas sarkozy au moins une
rachida dati qui n'a strictement rien
fait qu'est ce qu'elle a fait elle a
supprimé des juridictions de proximité
c'est à dire qu'elle a réduit l'accès
aux justices de la justice aux
justiciables et ça a continué comme ça
christiane taubira en réalité et
christiane taubira elle a eu un
magistère de la parole mais elle n'a
rien fait pour le fonctionnement de
l'institution judiciaire réellement
celui qui a essayé de faire quelque
chose ce n'est pas tout dire à ces
monsieurs urvoas qui l'a qui lui a
succédé et qui lui a vraiment tiré la
sonnette la sonnette d'alarmé en
essayant d'obtenir de bercy des moyens
supplémentaires souvenez vous c'est lui
qui dit la justice est en voie de
clochardisation
on est en 2016 ok monsieur macron est
élu qu'est ce qui est fait depuis que
monsieur macron était lui quasiment rien
et donc les problèmes s'accumulent le
retard s'accumule nous ce que nous
disons très très très clairement avec
les magistrats c'est que en effet il
faut doubler le nombre de magistrats
professionnels on en a neuf mille
aujourd'hui je rappelle qu'en 1920 il y
en avait huit mille pour une population
qu'à deux français qu'à doubler voilà
les greffiers il faut les doubler ce
n'est plus possible sans ces personnels
humains compétents formés l'institution
judiciaire ne peut pas fonctionner donc
là leur eric dupond moretti lui les îles
et pas tellement d'accord avec vous
parce qu'il dit mais moi j'ai réparé
d'urgence il a défendu son son bilan
humain de jetair gabriela talent qui
vient on soutient le porte parole du
gouvernement qui dit qu'il y aurait une
augmentation 30 % du budget de la
justice alors qu'est ce qu'on verra t on
des meutres est simplement que
l'augmentation du budget de la justice
qui est une réalité en effet 2 8% pas 30
% 30 % sur les cinq ans mais les 8%
cette année et sur les quatre ans
précédant quasiment quatre ans
précédents ça a été consacrée
essentiellement à l'administration
pénitentiaire pas au fonctionnement des
tribunaux
c'est à dire ces lieux où les citoyens
peuvent trouver limbes le moyen de faire
régler leurs différends par un tiers qui
est le juge et ça c'est un facteur de
paix sociale tant que 1
ministre comme monsieur dupont moretti
qui ce matin sur france inter
véritablement a été minable en essayant
de reporter la faute à la fois sur la
grève des avocats sur le fait de ses
prédécesseurs pourtant
oui mais juste mais peu importe en fait
vous savez monsieur dupont moretti
aujourd'hui il est il a changé de
clients sont gagnants c'est monsieur
macron donc il soutient tout ce que dit
monsieur macron avant ils soutenaient
les criminels ce qui est tout à son
honneur aujourd'hui il soutient un homme
politique et il a cessé porter la robe
est il assez c'est vraiment de porter la
robe il a endossé le costume du ministre
2 du président macro qui n'a aucun
intérêt pour l'institution judiciaire
absolument aucun et pourquoi tout
simplement parce que lui comme sans
doute ses prédécesseurs ne veut pas que
l'institution judiciaire puisse avoir du
pouvoir nous ce qu'on demande aux gens
de robe nous qui aimons notre métier
nous aimons notre métier nous aimons
défendre les gens et les juges m jugez
les justiciables mais ils veulent le
faire dans de bonnes conditions
si le juge ne peut pas juger dans de
bonnes conditions ça va se reporter
évidemment sur le justiciable au premier
chef tout le monde paye paye les paye
les pots cassés donc là il y à vraiment
la sonnette d'alarmé qui est plus que
tiré parce que nous sommes au bord de
l'implosion nous sommes au bord du burn
out nous avons des solutions pour
améliorer le fonctionnement de la
justice y compris dans son management
comme l'a indiqué monsieur dupont
moretti nous les connaissons les sujets
c'est pas ça ne date pas d'aujourd'hui
et les états généraux de la justice là
qui sont mis en place
et de la communication il se moque
vraiment du monde c'est la poudre de
perlimpinpin pas franchement ils nous
prennent pour des quetsches on a les
solutions des grands ateliers sur la
justice on les a on a on a travaillé on
sait ce qu'il faut faire nous avons
besoin d'avoir plus de juge plus de
greffiers nous avons besoin d'avoir la
fin de ces réformes sempiternelle qui
n'ont qu'un seul objet faire en sorte
que le justiciable sortent du circuit
judiciaire nous avons besoin d'avoir la
suppression du décret magin dit par
exemple sur les procédures d'appel
augmentation des places aux concours de
la magistrature a été annoncé mais mais
mais mais ça doit être fait de manier de
manière beaucoup beaucoup plus haut il
faut ouvrir beaucoup plus il faut faire
des concours spéciaux voilà et non pas
uniquement recruter des contractuels qui
sont certes peuvent être utiles peuvent
aider mais ce ne sont pas des magistrats
ou ce ne sont pas des greffiers or il ya
eu il ya dans la fonction de magistrat
ou dans la fonction de greffier il y a
une garantie qui est donnée à la fois à
la république et aux justiciables dans
l'exercice du métier et puis des
contractuels c'est des gens que vous
pouvez mettre dehors au bout de un an
deux ans trois ans si ça vous plait pas
alors les fonctionnaires comme les
magistrats ou les greffiers vous ne
pouvez pas les mettre dehors aujourd'hui
vous demande est reçue par bruno le
maire il ya eu une réunion ce soir pas
par bruno le maire un directeur de
cabinet d'un ferry ce quelqu'un c'est
lui le calme d'ailleurs elle 19 heures
et en effet il ya eu il y a eu un rendez
vous je n'ai pas eu de retour de ce
rendez vous mais ça montre vraiment le
peu de considération que kif donnée par
ce gouvernement à l'institution
judiciaire
quand on a une mobilisation de l'ampleur
de celle que nous à laquelle nous
assistons aujourd'hui qui a été je veux
dire des finales et elle est à la fois
inédite l'ailé enfin et et que la
réponse est d'être con reçu par un un
conseiller du cabinet blablabli et
blablabla c'est que véritablement on se
demande quel est le projet de monsieur
macron pour la justice donc je vous
avais en elle et bruno le maire est pas
tout simplement parce que qui en fait
aujourd'hui
tiens j'allais dire les les ficelles en
tout cas celui qui tient les cordons de
la bourse et bruno le maire ce n'est pas
monsieur nombreux moretti monsieur
dupont moretti ce même son cabinet ne
l'a pas choisi et donc lille a été
incapable de prendre ne serait-ce qu'un
magistrat qui soit en mesure de discuter
avec l'administration de bercy comme
l'avait fait par exemple jean jacques
urvoas qui avait eu l'intelligence de
recruter un haut fonctionnaire qui était
passé par bercy avant de l'intégrer dans
son cabinet donc voilà monsieur dupont
moretti c'est en réalité un
j'allais dire un saint peu importe ce
que monsieur dupont moretti nous nous
sommes adressés à celui qui pouvait nous
les satisfactions d'une manière ou d'une
autre et pas à celui au fond qui n'est
qu'une marionnette qui ne fait que
représenter son client monsieur macron
aujourd'hui quand vous voyez les
candidats à la présidence et alors je ne
demande pas ici dans d'en promouvoir
l'un ou l'autre mais enfin est-ce que ça
laisse tout de même de l'espoir est ce
que cette souffrance de la justice est
prise en compte d'une manière générale
par les candidats à la présidentielle où
l on se valent pardonnez moi d'abord
pour le moment que je souffre erreur de
ma part madame pécresse monsieur zemmour
madame le pen pour la droite de son job
c'est n'ont pas de programme ou spies
assez bas affiche à gauche le seul qui a
un programme c'est monsieur jean luc
mélenchon il ya un programme pour la
justice moi je pense qu'il doit est ce
programme-là doit impérativement être
musclé et c'est peut-être l'opportunité
pour les candidats à la présidentielle
qui ne cesse de nous parler de sécurité
et de police qu'ils s'intéressent enfin
une bonne fois pour toutes à
l'institution judiciaire qui est quand
même un élément essentiel dans un état
de droit démocratique
il n'y a pas de démocratie sans justice
ça n'est pas possible donc j'attends
aussi en tout cas c'est mon souhait que
ces candidats à la présidentielle
travail leurs programmes sur la question
deux pour répondre à la demande qui est
la demande certes des professionnels
mais nous ne le faisons pas pour nous
nous le faisons pour les citoyens pour
les justiciables c'est ça qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que nous ne sommes pas
dans une démarche corporatiste nous ne
demandons pas d'argent pour nous nous ne
demandons pas d'augmentation de salaire
non nous demandons des moyens humains
c'est-à-dire des femmes et des hommes
qui soit capable d'écouter les procès
qui soit capable de rendre des jugements
dans des délais raisonnables qui nous
disent pas à une dame qui vient pour une
pension alimentaire bonjour madame vous
revenez dans un an ou qu'ils nous disent
pas une jeune fille qui a été violée en
2016 à bas la cour d'assises traitera
votre dossier en 2023 par exemple ou qui
mettent pas 3 345 jugement devant le
conseil des prud'hommes on a le
sentiment que vous nous dites les
hôpitaux le monde de la santé dit la
même chose c'est tout simplement
aujourd'hui une défaillance majeure des
services publics qu'un abandon laisse
errer l'oubli je suis d'accord
effectivement on peut faire un parallèle
dans ce qui se passe pour tous les
services publics que ce soit le service
public de la police que ce soit le
service public de la santé ou celui de
l'éducation on a on assiste exactement à
la même chose dans pour le service
public de 2 de la justice et là on voit
bien qu'en réalité ça correspond à des
logiques à des choix politiques qui ont
été faits depuis effectivement ça ne
date pas de monsieur macro mais macron
les à amplifier mais ce sont des choix
politiques qui sont faits de détricoter
ce qui a été mis en place par le conseil
national de la résistance après la
deuxième guerre mondiale de d'offrir des
services publics à tous les citoyens un
service public dont on est bien content
qu'on l'ait bien content d'avoir quand
même donc nous nous battons en effet
pour le maintien du service public de la
justice et nous espérons que entouraient
nous souhaitons être entendu merci
beaucoup car les magazines en tout cas
on a entendu ce soir merci à vous